Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Genj. Heute bin ich Ihre Ärzte.
Bevor wir mit dem Anamnese-Gespräch anfangen, möchte ich Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, ist in Ordnung, Frau Doktor.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Herbert Wehner.
Können Sie Ihren Vor- und Nachname buchstabieren?
Ja, Herbert, mit H-E-R-B-E-R-T.
Und der Nachname ist Wehner.
W-E-H-N-E-R.
Halb Wehner.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin jetzt 83 Jahre alt.
83.
Okay, wann sind Sie geworden?
5. März 1940.
1940. Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
Frau Doktor, ich war einmal 1,75 m, aber ich habe mich lange nicht mehr gemessen.
Sind Sie kleiner geworden wegen des Anfängens?
Bestimmt, ja.
Können Sie noch einmal sagen, die Größe?
1,75 m.
75, ja, danke schon.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
70 kg.
Danke für die Informationen, Herr Wehner.
Was führt Sie heute zu mir?
Frau Doktor, ich komme jetzt hauptsächlich, weil ich jetzt seit gestern Schüttelfrost habe.
Ich hatte jetzt 2, 3 Tage Fieber und heute habe ich dann auch Schüttelfrost bekommen.
Und das ist der Grund, warum ich jetzt hier zu Ihnen komme.
Okay.
Ich fühle mich insgesamt auch sehr schwach und habe auch nicht so viel gegessen in den letzten Tagen.
Ich habe auch Übelkeit und musste auch ein paar Mal erbrechen.
Okay.
Haben Sie in den letzten 2, 3 Tage Stuhl abgegeben?
Also ich muss sagen, ich bin jetzt seit ein paar Tagen verstopft.
Also der letzte Stuhlgang ist glaube ich schon 4 oder 5 Tage mindestens her.
Okay, 4 oder 5 Tage.
Ist das normal für Sie oder ist das normal?
Nee, sonst habe ich eigentlich jeden Tag oder jeden zweiten Tag spätestens Stuhlgang.
Okay.
Nicht normal.
Haben Sie Bauchschmassen?
Also mir tut der ganze Leib weh.
Also nicht nur Bauch, sondern auch der gesamte Rücken, also der ganze Leib tut mir weh.
Bauch und Rücken schmassen haben Sie?
Ja.
Haben Sie Ihr Fieber gemessen?
Ja, es war heute bis 39,3 sogar.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber senkenes Mittel eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe dann Parazitaumol genommen.
Okay, aber trotzdem hat es gestiegen.
Ich will vorerst, habe ich heute auch bekommen.
Haben Sie Beschwerte mit Wasser lassen?
Also ich trinke halt wenig, deswegen habe ich das Gefühl, dass es nicht so wie früher ist mit Wasser lassen.
Sie trinken weniger als früher.
Ja, ich muss habe Übelkeit und wie gesagt, ich muss erbrechen.
Okay, ist das auch in der letzten 2-3 Tage?
Ja.
Sie trinken weniger, also Sie haben weniger Wasser lassen meistens normal?
Ja, richtig und es ist nicht so wie früher normal.
Okay.
Haben Sie etwas Ungemöhnliches gegessen vor 3 Tage?
Kann ich nicht sagen, Frau Doktor.
Das war ganz normal.
Was essen Sie an einem Tag normalerweise?
Unterschiedlich, also je nachdem, was ich mir auch selbst mache.
Ob es Gemüse, vielleicht, also ausgewogener Ernährung haben Sie, oder?
Ja, so weit man das machen kann.
Wie können Sie einschätzen Ihre Bauch und rücken Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskala?
Von 1 bis 10, sind Sie stark?
Sie meinen jetzt stark mit Zahlen oder wie?
Ja, mit Zahlen, genau.
10 ist die stärkste Teste.
Die stärkste, okay.
Ja.
Ich würde sagen so 6, 7 vielleicht.
6, 7, okay.
Und auch seit 3 Tagen haben Sie diese Schmerzen nicht seit gestern?
Die Schmerzen sind eigentlich jetzt seit gestern eher.
Ja, sie sind seit gestern.
Okay.
Jetzt habe ich auch Kopfschmerzen bekommen.
Kopfschmerzen auch, okay.
Ja.
Ich würde gerne Ihre Vorgeschichte, der Krankenvorgeschichte etwas fragen.
Haben Sie kranke Monitore?
Ja, ich habe eine Prostata für Größerung.
Okay.
Seit wann?
Von zumindest seit 15 Jahren bestimmt schon.
Seit 15, okay.
Dann habe ich einen Herzschrittmacher.
Okay.
Ich habe ungefähr seit 10, 15 Jahren ungefähr.
Und da habe ich dann auch jetzt vor ungefähr 3 Jahren auch ein Schlag-Anfall gehabt.
Okay.
Da hat sich aber alles gut wieder erholt zum Glück.
Ja, das ist sehr gut, ja.
Und ich hatte mal einen Sturz und habe mir die Hüfte gebrochen,
dass ich ein künstliches Hüftgelenk habe auf der rechten Seite.
Rechte Seite.
Und habe auch schon lange mit Bandscheiben Probleme.
War es ein Vorfall oder Vorwölfung, wenn ich da sitze?
Ich weiß nicht genau, aber es mussten nie operiert werden ein bisschen.
Aber ich habe damit schon seit über 20 Jahren zu tun, ja.
Okay, aber wurden Sie nicht operiert?
Nein.
Okay.
Ja.
Achso, dann habe ich vielleicht vergessen, aber das ist auch schon lange her.
Über 30 Jahre hatte ich auch mal Nierensteine gehabt.
Aber das ist schon lange her.
Okay.
Wurden Sie im Krankenhaus behandelt wegen dieser Nierensteine?
Damals, ja.
Ja.
Wann war diese?
Das ist so lange her, 30 Jahre, das ist bestimmt schon vor 30 Jahren.
Okay, ja.
Nehmen Sie bestimmt Medikamente gegen diese Erkrankungen, können Sie erwähnen?
Ja, also ich habe einmal Blutverdienung mit Xarelto.
Xarelto.
Genau, ja.
Und dann habe ich noch ein Medikament wegen Prostateffektgrösung,
als Duo-Dart.
Duo-Dart.
Und andere Medikamente habe ich bisher nicht gebraucht.
Okay, Sie haben nicht gebraucht.
Sie nehmen nur zur Blutverdienung Xarelto und gegen Prostateffekt.
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie allergien gegen etwas?
Also war mal fraglich, ob ich auf Penicillinallergie,
weil ich mal mal Ausschlag bekommen hatte.
Das habe ich immer den Ärzten gesagt,
dass es vielleicht Penicillinallergie besteht.
Okay, aber es wurde nicht festgestellt, aber das war fraglich.
Ja, das war fraglich.
Okay.
Ja.
Das berücksichtigen wir im Krankenhaus.
Und haben Sie weitere andere allergien?
Nein, sonst ist es nicht bekannt.
Ja, traurig?
Nein.
Sie haben noch nicht geraucht?
Also als Jugendlicher vielleicht mal ein bisschen, aber...
Nicht lange Zeit, haben Sie?
Nein.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, trinken auch keinen Alkohol.
Okay.
Das ist eine Routinefrage, die ich jeder Patient stellen muss.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, ich habe keine Erfahrung mit Drogen.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Familienstatus etwas fragen.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verwittet.
Wir sind verwittet.
Wohne Sie allein?
Ja, ich wohne alleine.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe Kinder.
Okay, sind Sie gesund?
Ja, die haben auch verschiedene kleinere Krankheiten,
aber nichts ernst.
Nicht relevante?
Nein.
Okay.
Sie wohnen in Ihrer eigene Wohnung, oder?
Ja, ja.
Und Sie sind in Rentner, Sie sind in Rentnerzeit, glaube ich.
Was haben Sie früher gemacht als Beruf?
Also ich war Beamter im Finanzamt.
Also Sie haben Brurarbeit gemacht.
Wie meint Sie?
Am PC oder am Tisch, am Meister?
Ja, das ist eine Büroarbeit.
Wir brauchen keine Kraft bei der Arbeit.
Nein, das war eine Büro tätigkeit.
Ich muss kurz gucken, ob ich alles geschrieben habe.
Sie strahlen dich im März aus, oder?
Also in die Brust strahlen Sie aus?
Ich wusste nicht, aber ich kann es nur schwer blockalisieren.
Die Furzschmerzen haben Sie?
Ja, vom Rücken, der Bauch, der ganze Leib tut weh.
Besuchen Sie Ihren Hausarzt regelmäßig?
Ja, so einigermaßen, ich gehe nicht auf zum Arzt.
Okay, Sie haben keine Brustschmerzen und kein Brusten?
Nein.
Nur Kopfschmerzen?
Ja.
Und Sie fühlen sich kraftlos?
Ja, richtig.
Wenn ich vor Zusammenfasse, Sie haben seit zwei, drei Tagen Fieber,
aber seit gestern haben Sie noch Stoffrost und Brückenschmerzen,
also Leibschmerzen.
Und seit fünf Tagen ungefähr haben Sie Verstopfung.
Und in diesem Zeitraum haben Sie auch nicht so viel getrunken
und wenig Wasser lassen, haben Sie gemacht.
Ja.
Okay, und die Schmerzen sind ungefähr 6 bis 7 von 10.
Haben Sie so eingeschätzt?
Richtig, ja.
Gibt es, dass die Schmerzen lindern oder verstärken,
können Sie beurteilen?
Wenn ich lege, sind Sie besser, wenn ich mich bewege, sind Sie besser?
Ja, beim Liegen ist besser,
aber bei Bewegung ist es vielleicht doch ein bisschen mehr als ein Liegen.
Also so ist es möglich, wenn ich mich zu bewegen, ja.
Okay, Herr Schwenow.
Ich habe alle Fragen gestellt.
Familienanalyse?
Ja, Familienanalyse.
Ich habe vergessen.
Ich glaube, Ihre Eltern sind noch nicht am Leben, oder?
Nein, sie sind schon gestorben.
Woran sind sie gestorben?
Hatten Sie wichtige Erkrankungen?
Also meine Mutter hatte schon einige Erkrankungen.
Die hatte Diabetes, Bluthochdruck.
Und auch Herz-Herrprobleme gehabt.
Ich habe dann mit einem Herzversagen gestorben.
Und mein Vater, der ist schon lange tot.
Der hatte eine kurze Krankheit.
Er ist mit 60 Jahren schon gestorben,
aber ganz genau weiß ich nicht, woran er gestorben ist.
War es eine bösartige Erkrankung, oder?
Er war nicht gesagt dann, aber ich weiß nicht genau.
Er ist von einem wenigen Tagen krank geworden,
und gestorben.
Okay.
Jetzt hätte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer aktuelle Beschwerden.
Deswegen bin ich zu ruck.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstolpern?
Also meine Herzstolpern, es ist schon lange.
Ich hatte gesagt, ich habe einen Herzschrittmacher bekommen.
Dafür war das immer wieder der Rhythmus anders.
Ich habe es immer wieder vorruf,
und deswegen ist es so gemacht,
dass ich einen Herzschrittmacher bekommen habe.
Okay.
Ich merke manchmal noch, dass Herzstolpern.
Haben Sie Gewichtsveränderungen in letzter Zeit abnehmen oder zunehmen?
Ja, in den letzten drei bis vier Tagen habe ich schon Gewicht abgenommen.
Aber in den letzten zwei, drei Tagen,
nur da Sie wenig essen.
Nein.
Und Sie nehmen keine Medikamente wegen Ihres Herzschrittsmachers?
Sie nehmen nur Blutverdünnung?
Richtig, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie geschwollene Beine bemerkt?
Nein.
Okay.
Herr Rehner,
haben Sie eine Darmpferschluss?
Ja.
Um diese Diagnose zu bestätigen,
werde ich sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Und dann mache ich,
lasse ich eine Röntgenaufnahme durch.
Ja.
Und ich werde Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Ja, vom Bauch.
Genau.
Und ich werde auch ein EKG schreiben,
dass Sie im Herzen krank sind.
Wir müssen auch diese Huckeln beobachten.
Ja.
Und ich glaube, Sie müssen momentan im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Okay.
Ich habe auch meine Sache mitgenommen,
weil ich dachte, ich müsste im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Ja, da haben Sie gut gemacht.
Verlockte, ich habe auch noch eine Patientverfügung.
Soll ich die Ihnen geben oder durch die Ihnen später geben?
Wie wollen Sie das haben?
Ich habe noch einen Teil zu versuchen,
kann ich das abnehmen.
Da habe ich nämlich reingeschrieben,
dass ich dann auch keine intensiv-medizinischen Maßnahmen
haben möchte.
Ach so, okay.
Haben Sie dabei?
Ja, ich habe dabei, ja,
eine Patientverfügung.
Wir haben ein gutes Gespräch,
kann ich bekommen.
Okay.
Ich hoffe, Sie fragen mich noch.
Sonst ist alles klar,
ich hoffe, Sie können mir helfen.
Ja, danke schön.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Das ist gut, Roger.
Erst mal.
Wir haben erst mal sehr, sehr gut.
Aber es ist nicht erst mal, glaube ich,
ja?
Ja, an der Stelle haben wir vielmals Simulation gemacht.
Ja, das ist so.
Das ist nicht so schlecht, aber man ist sicher.
Ja, ich meine erst mal, ja.
Ja, weitere Fragen oder Kommentare?
Sie sind ein Kollege.
War Sie schon in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, er war nicht im Ausland.
Ich hätte vorgeschlagen,
dass Sie bei alten Leuten,
muss man manchmal etwas nachbohren,
bei bestimmten Sachen,
um sich nochmal nachzusehen,
um sich nochmal zu erzielen.
Da gibt es Fragen, die man starten kann.
Wenn Kollegen keine Fragen haben,
möchte ich gerne ein paar Fragen stellen.
Bitte schön.
Wie sah Ihr Ihr Erbruch aus?
Ach so, das war mir.
War magend.
Es war ein bisschen,
es war ein bisschen,
es war sehr sauer, Mageninhalt.
Ja, am letzten Stuhlgang,
auch,
dieser
Stuhlgang war
nicht anders als sonst, so wie immer.
Und ürin?
Bitte?
Ürin?
Nein, war nicht grün der Stuhlgang.
Die Schmerzen sind größer als die Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen sind noch größer als die Schmerzen.
Langsamer?
Sind eher Dumpfe Schmerzen?
Die Schmerzen sind mit der Zeit verschlechtert oder?
Ja, seit gestern hat er Schmerzen und ja, seit gestern ist es schlimmer geworden, ja.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen sie auch wieder weg oder?
Ja, sie sind fast dauerhaft, ja.
Sind Sie schon einmal, hatten Sie so etwas früher schon einmal?
Nein, hat er noch nicht gehabt.
Okay, das war es.
Okay.
Gut, weitere Fragen.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe ein paar Fragen.
Haben Sie im Stuhl Blutung bemerken?
Kein Blut gesehen, nein.
Und wo genau im Bauch, im Anfang Schmerzen, rechts oder links Seite anfängt?
Kann er nichts lokalisieren, das ist Gesamtbauchrücken.
Okay, danke.
Wenn du alte Leute manchmal nicht so gut beschreiben, ja.
Haben Sie Schmerzen bei Wasser lassen?
Was heißt das auf Fachbegriff?
Diesuri oder Alguri.
Alguri ist Schmerzen, genau.
Was ist Diesuri?
Nein, nein, das ist nicht das.
Manchmal sind sie noch nie verwendet.
Diesuri ist eigentlich Schwierigkeiten Wasser zu lassen in jeder Form.
Ja, kann Schmerzbedingungen sein, kann aber auch andere Sachen haben.
Und Alguri ist normalerweise das Schmerzhaft Wasserlassen.
Das müssen Sie fragen bei bei alten Leuten, die Antworten nicht sagen,
einfach Schwierigkeit beim Wasserlassen.
Also er hat auch ein bisschen Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen,
aber er hat auch Diesuri beschweren,
also er kann nicht so normal Wasser lassen, wenn er möchte.
Ja, also Schwierigkeiten die Blase auch zu entleeren.
Also Diesuri und Alguri beschweren, das hat beides, all beides, ja.
Welche oft verwendet?
Also ich sehe oft, dass viele Kollegen schreiben Diesuri,
wenn sie meinen, dass es so schmerzhaft, also brennbar Wasser lassen zum Beispiel.
Aber normalerweise ist das, ist das mit Alguri,
wird das bezeichnet brennbar Wasserlassen.
Diesuri ist eher, wenn zum Beispiel die Blase nicht ganz entleert werden kann
oder einfach das Gefühl nicht normal Wasser lassen zu können.
Danke schön.
Das hat er Patient, ja.
Also hat vor allem Diesuri beschweren, er kann nicht normal Wasser lassen.
Und er hat auch wenig Urin, das haben Sie auch gefragt, glaube ich.
Das nennt man wie im Fachbegriff, wenn man wenig Wasser lässt.
Oligorin.
Oligorin, genau.
Und was ist, wenn man oft Wasser lässt?
Oft, Polyurin.
Das ist viel, Polyurin ist viel Wasser.
Polyurin, Polyurin.
Sie haben gesagt Apopilis erlitten.
Könnten Sie genau beschreiben,
welche, irgendwelche Körper...
Hemiparesis links.
Aber wieder vollständig zurückgebildet.
Also war vielleicht, dann,
nachdem, wie lange es gelauert hat,
vielleicht ein Print oder wirklich ein Schlaganfall,
der jetzt wenig Folgen hatte für ihn.
Okay, weitere Fragen?
Oder haben wir das Wichtigste, glaube ich, haben wir gefragt?
Was man vielleicht noch fragen könnte,
ist, weil Sie haben ja gesagt,
Verdacht auf Darmverschluss und so was.
Also eine Frage ist ja gestellt worden,
nach der Frage, wie das aussieht,
wird und zweite Frage wäre, ob er Windabgang hat.
Ja, Windabgang, genau.
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Er hat Windabgang, aber...
Er hat Windabgang.
Wurde Sie operiert?
Sehr gute Frage, ja.
Operiert ist er am, an der Hüfte, aber was Sie fragen,
wollen ist, was anderes, glaube ich, gell?
Das ist eine Bauchoperation, wenn man Sie fragen will.
Das ist eine wichtige Frage, nein, keine Bauchoperation bisher.
Gut, ich glaube, dann können wir zur Vorstellung gehen.
Ja, wir können.
Ich fange an.
Das ist der Moderator, einverstanden.
Bitte schön, Neujam.
Guten Abend, Herr Obatz.
Heute möchte ich Ihnen einen neuen Patient vorstellen.
Er ist Herbert Wenner.
Herr Wenner ist 83 Jahre alt.
Er berichtet über
seit gestern bestehende Stilfrost
und seit 2-3 Tagen
erhöhte Temperatur.
Heute hat er gemessen
das Fieberlag bei
39,3.
Er hat schwache
Gefühle.
Er klagt über Inapäthanz und Nausea.
Seit 5 Tagen
hat er Obstipation.
Des Weiteren berichtet der Patient
Bauch- und Rückenschmerzen.
Abdominelle Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt
bei 6 bis 7 von 10.
Sie sind die Füße Schmerzen.
Beim Liegen
bessern sich die Schmerzen.
Bei vegetative Anamnese
berichtet der Patient
Oliguri.
Bis auf Oliguri ist die vegetative Anamnese
unauffällig.
Der Patient leidet
an folgende Erkrankungen.
Er hat seit 15 Jahren
Prozative Perplasie.
Dagegen nimmt er Dordats.
Aber die Dosierung musste ich
erfragen.
Er hat vor 3 Jahren
in Surt.
Er war vollständig
besser.
Auf der rechten Seite
hat er
Prozese.
Er trägt
ein Herzschrittmacher seit
15 Jahren.
Er hat noch
Diskusprolaps oder Prozision.
Aber dagegen wurde nichts gemacht.
Auch
Urolitiasis
hat er damals.
Medikamente sind
Xarelta.
Und Dordat.
Ansonsten nimmt er keine Medikamente.
Er hat eine
Penicillin-Allergie.
Er raucht nicht und trinkt kein Alkohol.
Bei der
Familienanamnese
ist das bekannt.
Die Mutter hat an Diabetes
und Arterelleparthonie.
Herz
Insuffizienz gelitten.
Der Vater hat eine
kurze Erkrankung.
Aber das ist auch unbekannt.
Er ist
Rentner.
Aber damals war er Berter.
Er wohnt in seiner Wohnung.
Die Anamnestige
hat eine andere Angabe.
Am ersten war er ein Eläubis.
Aber ich habe gelernt,
der Patient kann Wind abgeben.
Dafür spricht,
dass der Patient seit 5 Tagen
keinen Stuhl gehabt hat.
Und die Fuse
Bauchschmerzen nicht lokalisieren können.
Diese
Sprüche,
diese Vegetative an der Anamnese
und in Appetenz auch.
Differenzial Diagnostisch kommen.
Diartekulitis
oder wegen Herz Insuffizienz
eine
Abdomine, ein gutes Atom.
Aber da bin ich nicht sicher.
Warum denkt ihr,
hat er beim Ilios Fieber und Schädelpost?
Ist das ein normales Symptom bei Ilios?
Bei normalen Mechanischen Ilios
sind sie nicht normal,
aber bei Parallelischen Ilios würde ich erwarten.
Es kann sein, aber
ist es häufig, dass Patienten mit Ilios Fieber
Schädelpost haben?
Eigentlich nicht so gut.
Kann der Ilios ein Nebensymptom sein?
Von irgendwas anderem?
Von etwas anderem.
Ein Turm würde ich für unwahrscheinlich halten,
weil er in letzter Zeit
keine Gewichtsabnahme hat.
Wenn ich von Ihnen höre,
dass Patient Schädelfrost und Fieber
immer gleich ein Infektion hat,
hat er in Bauch ein Infektion?
Und wegen
Schädelfrost und Fieber würde ich auch
ein paar kreatives Denken.
Das würde sein.
Aber keine Alkoholgeschichte
oder eine würzelformige Schmerz.
Was sind denn die häufigsten
Ursachen für Infektionen
bei normalen Patienten, die häufigsten?
Meinen Sie im Abtome?
Generell.
Wenn ein Patient mit Fieber und Schädelfrost kommt,
dann ist es eine Plämonie.
Aber hat er keine Symptome dafür?
Was noch Piole und Effritis könnte es auch sein?
Das sind die zwei häufigsten Ursachen
für Fieber und Infektionen.
Also respiratorische
oder Infektionen der Handwege.
Die zwei häufigsten Ursachen.
Haben die diesbezüglich angabt,
die darauf hindeuten könnten?
Ja, vielleicht Rückenschmerzen.
Aber das könnte auch ein Grund sein.
Wir können ja auch reagieren
mit dem Bauch bei Piole und Effritis.
Vor allem bei den alten Leuten.
Was würden Sie jetzt diagnostisch machen?
Sie haben ein Patient untersucht.
Der Bauch ist weich.
Damengroeuche ist ein bisschen sperrlich.
Könnte in Richtung paralytischer Illusion
gehen vielleicht?
Was machen Sie für weitere Untersuchungen bei den Patienten?
Ich würde Klopschmerzhaft
auf der Nierenlage überprüfen.
Wenn Sie Klopschmerzhaft sind,
werden Sie ein Zeichen für Piole und Effritis.
Als körperliche Untersuchung.
Das heißt, dass die
keine Operspannung oder Resistenz
ist.
Nein, also kein akuten Bauch,
nur ein bisschen sperrliche Damengroeuche.
Könnte vielleicht oder wenig Damengroeuche
für paralytische Illusion sprechen,
aber keine Zeichen von mechanischen Illusion.
Was sind dann Zeichen für einen mechanischen Illusion?
Bei körperlichen Untersuchungen würde ich
vor dem Illusion erhöhte Damengroeuche
erwarten.
Wie bezeichnet man diese erhöhten Damengroeuche?
Lebhafte Damengroeuche.
Wie kann man die noch genauer bezeichnen?
Bei mechanischen Illusion.
Im bestimmten Begriff.
Hochgestellte Damengroeuche.
Oder auch manchmal metallische Charakter.
Bei mechanischen Illusion.
Die hat ja nichts.
Der Bauch ist jetzt nicht hart.
Da ist nicht sehr ab der gespannt.
Das heißt, zu viele Hüte haben.
Könnte sein.
Jetzt haben Sie den körperlichen Untersuch.
Haben auch die Lunge abgehört.
Haben Sie auch nichts festgestellt.
Herz haben Sie abgehört.
Das ist auch kein Problem.
Würden Sie weitere diagnostische Maßnahmen machen?
Was würden Sie im Vornehmen bei den Patienten?
Bei Labor würde ich
Blutbild- und Entzündungsparameter
und Nähe und Werte.
Und auch Geländungsparameter
veranlassen.
Und noch würde ich ein Sonografie-Abdomen durchführen.
Wenn Sie schon Blut abnehmen,
was machen Sie noch außer diesen Sachen, die Sie gesagt haben?
Urin starten sich.
Ja, das machen Sie auch.
Wenn Sie Blut abnehmen, nehmen Sie etwas ab.
Paröchen, Serum,
Edita, Serum, Perparin vielleicht.
Was machen Sie noch?
Denken Sie an die Infektion.
An Kultur.
Ja, Blutkulturen.
Gefahr, dass eine Bakterie nie bietet.
Eine Urin starten.
Was machen Sie noch?
Urin starten sich.
Ein Sonografie-Abdomen-Bauch.
Vielleicht könnte eine Erharte,
damals Steine, eine Freundschaft,
vielleicht könnte es auch eine Ursache sein.
Wo müssen Sie genau hingucken bei den Patienten?
Wenn Sie jetzt sehen,
dass die Nieren nicht gut aussehen,
haben Sie ein bisschen gestaut.
Nachgucken Sie.
Gerade bei diesen Patienten.
Wenn Sie an der Anamnese denken.
Herz.
Nicht mal aus anderes,
sondern in der Anamnese.
Tabletten ein, auch für Dordate.
Vielleicht.
Die BP-Hal ist verhandelt.
Das ist ein Rösser.
Was sieht man dann?
Ein Hahn verhalten.
Richtig.
Eine volle Hahnblase.
Das wäre ein Notfall.
Die W-Werden sind seit 2-3 Tagen.
Deswegen habe ich diese für unwahrscheinlich gehalten.
Das könnte sein.
Das ist ein Risiko,
dass eine Piole ne Fritismat bei den Patienten macht.
Sie gucken Nieren nach.
Wenn Sie da ein Stau sehen,
dann gucken Sie auf jeden Fall unten nach.
Ob die Hahnblase gefüllt ist.
Mit dem Füll des Sagen,
der Patient soll mal versuchen, Wasser zu lassen.
Das ist ein Risiko.
Manchmal haben Sie die Blase nicht entleernt.
Dann können sie auch mal so voll sein.
Sagen Sie, gehen Sie mal auf Toilette?
Oder waren Sie mal Urin?
Dann gucken wir noch mal nach.
Wenn es immer noch voll ist,
dann hat er eine Entleerungsstörung.
Hat der Patient auch.
Was machen Sie noch?
Manchmal gibt es nicht,
auch wenn die Patienten keine Luftnot haben.
Bauchschmerzen und Fieber gibt es auch mal
eine Basalepneumonie.
Sie machen Bauchschmerzen,
dann selten mal.
Deswegen Röntgen, Porax ist gut.
Einzige wäre so viel in dieser Fall.
Was meinen Sie?
Das ist schon eine strahlende Belastung.
Wir müssen nicht alle Untersuchungen an einem Tag machen.
Wir müssen Schritt für Schritt.
Ein Patient mit einer Unklanginfektion kommt.
Das gehört auf jeden Fall die Lunge dazu.
Das ist kein strahlender Belastung.
Vor allen Dingen ein Röntgenbild.
Das ist ein Vergleich zu den ganzen Sachen,
die Sie sonst machen, minimal.
Ich habe schon gelesen, dass Sie Kollegen CT machen möchten.
Das ist ein Hundertelefon vom CT.
Würden Sie CT-Abdomen?
Wenn wir diskutieren, also nicht primär.
Aber wenn Sie mit den ganzen Sachen,
die Sie gemacht haben, nicht weiterkommen,
kann man das weiteren Verlauf überlegen.
Aber das Schritt für Schritt, nicht gleich mit dem CT anfangen.
Dann haben Sie jetzt Verdacht.
Entzündungswertige Lokocytose der Patienten, CRP ist hoch.
Sie haben auf jeden Fall Infektionen.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Die Dinierer ist gestaut.
Die Blase ist voll.
Sie haben auch eine Handtransportstörung mit Ascendingen,
der Pylonephritis.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Da diese Erkrankung sehr kompliziert werden kann,
würde ich mit Breit-Spektrum Antibiotika anfangen.
Je nach Blutkultur würde ich meine Therapie umstellen.
Ich würde die Plüssigkeit durch Infusion verabreichen.
Worauf müssen Sie aber auch passen?
Der Patient hat schon Herz,
dass er sich nicht mehr auf den Kopf hat.
Ich habe auch eine andere Erkrankung.
Der Patient hat schon Herz schrittmachen.
Ich muss gleichzeitig ein Handtreibendes-Mittel
über Infusion geben.
Wenn Sie das machen,
stippte der Patient.
Sprechen mit den Integrations-Solomias erst mal Patientverfügung berichten.
Weil der Patient eine Patientverfügung hat,
und deswegen intensive medizinische Behandlung nicht möchte.
Das ist eine gute Frage, wobei das eigentlich ein Thema für eine eigene Sitzung.
Es gibt allgemeine Patientverfügung, die man im Internet runterladen kann.
Da steht zum Beispiel drin, so im Falle, dass ich nicht mehr einwägungsfähig bin
und jetzt keine Chance auf bessere besteht, möchte ich keine künstliche Beatmung,
künstliche Nierenwäsche, Dialys usw.
Das muss man im Einzelfall besprechen mit den Patienten.
Es kann sein, dass er die Verfügung hat, aber wenn sie sagen,
diese Krankheit ist mit Antibiotika gut zu behandeln,
und wären sie trotzdem bereit, wenn es notwendig ist, auch auf in der Situation zu gehen,
willigen manche dann doch noch mal ein.
Das muss man dann im Einzelfall besprechen.
Das mit der Patientfügung ist zwar wichtig, aber man muss es immer auf den Einzelfallen
auch noch mal diskutieren, mit Patient oder auch Angehörigen.
Aber das ist ein anderes Thema, glaube ich.
Das führt jetzt hier zu weit.
Von der Diagnostik haben wir, glaube ich, das wichtigste, so glaube ich, besprochen,
so, als ich mich jetzt erinnern kann.
Und was Sie gesagt haben, ich habe es am Anfang vielleicht auch überhört,
Sie wollten eine Patientflüssigkeit geben und auch noch handragende Medikamente.
Ich möchte eine Diagnose, eine Differenzialdiagnose,
als keine Risik, hierzufügen, medial infakt.
Kann sein, ja, geht es auch manchmal, ja.
Gerade wenn der Patient so Probleme hat, kann auch mal eine Sekunde
dann zu Infektionszeichen führen, richtig, ja.
Durch eine grotische, durch eine große Darmbahn, zum Beispiel, ja.
Aber was ich sagen wollte, den Patienten Flüssigkeit geben ist gut,
aber Sie müssen vorher gewährleisten, dass er die Flüssigkeit auch abgeben kann.
Das heißt, diesen Patienten, wenn Sie dem Flüssigkeit geben
und noch Dioretika und dass Sie ihn an Katheter legen, dann machen Sie es nur schlechter.
Das heißt, da müssen Sie erstmal die Handtransportstörung beseitigen,
meistens durch einen Ur-Uretral-Katheter.
Und dann können Sie die Flüssigkeit geben, wenn es notwendig ist.
Das ist eine Diöneil-Decompletion.
Kommt darauf an, ob er Ilos hatte oder nicht, aber da hat Frau Doktor gesagt,
Sie möchten auch nochmal ein rundgebildes Abdomens machen.
Wenn man da jetzt keine Spiegel sieht, muss man das nicht unbedingt machen,
weil es gibt oft reflektorische Darm-Atoni oder Subilius bei Pyronephritis.
Das kann mal sein.
Wenn die es, sag ich mal, nicht massiv weiter erbrechen
und sie schnell mit der Behandlung beginnen,
kann man auch den Patienten manchmal noch ohne Magen sonnen lassen.
Kommt auf den Einzelfall an.
Also Dioretika, nur wenn die Handtransportstörung behoben ist,
ist das nicht vorher.
Gut, aber Sie waren noch nicht fertig, glaube ich,
mit der Flüssigkeit haben Sie gesagt.
Was geben Sie noch, was das Wichtigste in so einem Fall?
Er hat eine Spasmolitikon, vielleicht...
Das kann man überlegen, ja.
Könnte dich massen lindern?
Ja.
Antibiotika haben wir schon.
Antibiotikon, welches nehmen Sie dann beim Patienten?
Ein Band, Breitband-Spektrum.
Aber an den Namen erinnere ich mich nicht momentan.
Der Patent hat Penicillinallergie?
Ja.
Ich würde den Fluoro-Cinolone oder Van-Komissin wählen.
Also bei einem Verdacht auf Penicillinallergie
würde ich dann auch das so machen, ja.
Van-Komissin nicht, aber es wird Fluoro-Cinolone wählen.
Aber in Deutschland ist es so, dass jetzt in den letzten Jahren
die Fluoro-Cinolone sehr in Verrufe gekommen sind.
Also es gibt immer in Deutschland diese rote Handbriefe.
Weiß nicht, ob Sie das kennen. Kennen Sie rote Handbriefe?
Ja, Rotelister.
Das sind Briefe, die an alle Ärzte geschickt werden,
mit Warnhinweisen, auch Medikamentennebenwirkungen
oder Medikamentenprobleme.
Und von Fluoro-Cinolone gibt es deshalb sehr, sehr viele,
sodass die meisten Kollegen in Fluoro-Cinolone fast gar nicht mehr geben
aufgrund dieser Probleme, die da beschrieben worden sind.
Ich, in solchem Fall, würde ich das glaube ich schon als Reservenantibiotikum
und verdacht auf Penicillinallergie in Erwägung ziehen.
Fluoro-Cinolone, ja.
Aber Sie müssen den Patienten mittlerweile extra aufklären
über diese spezielle Nebenwirkung mit so einem Patientenaufklärung.
Musst man?
Ja, so ist empfohlen, ja.
Wenn Sie einen Fluoro-Cinolone geben, sollten Sie den aufklären, ja.
Weil davor gewarnt wird mittlerweile.
Okay.
Gut.
Ansonsten kann man auch immer überlegen, ob man, also ist ja oft so,
dass Penicillinallergie nicht unbedingt auch auf zäphalosporine
sich ausdehnen muss.
Einzelte kann man auch über Breitband Antibiotika-Ausdokum
der zäphalosporine mal nachdenken, ja.
Wäre eine Option.
Gut.
Also Antibiotika ist wichtigstens im Fall, ja.
Ganz schnell, ohne lange Warten.
Schnell behandeln.
Weil, dass die Komplikationsrate, Urosepsis, ist
Urosepsis, ja, genau, fatal, ja.
Okay.
Gut.
Weitere Therapieempfälmung oder Empfehlung zur Diagnostik
bei den Patienten?
Empfehlung.
Ich gucke gerade mal nach im Chat, was die Kollegen ausgeschrieben haben.
So, kurz.
Jedem Teil müsste wie eine Kardiologe geblieben sein, ja.
Ja, der Patient nimmt seine Medikamente,
oder seine Medikamente reichen nicht, eigentlich.
Deswegen muss er eine Kardiologe aufsuchen.
Ja, sehr gut, ja.
Machen wir unbedingt, ja.
Und sonst kann man auch nochmal, wenn die Prostata groß ist.
Das ist vielleicht eine Erologe.
Richtig, ja.
Ja, genau.
Das habe ich gelesen.
Für Kinder muss man auch Sinusitis denken, ja.
Bei Kindern muss man an viele Sachen denken, ja.
Sinusitis oder Otitis ist oft ein Problem.
Lavman oder Supos, also Abführmaßnahmen,
kann man probieren, wenn der Patient Obstipation hat, ja.
Zum Beispiel, Pisa-Colidotropfen oder Sepsion, ja.
Genau.
Oder wenn er in Ilios hat im Röntgenbild und klinisch mit Abwehrspannung,
dann muss man auch Magensonde legen, ja.
Und die Empfehlung der Patientin,
Trinkmangel zu,
Auftrinkmangel zu versichten?
Ja, also wenn er Ilios hat, dann genau,
da muss er Nahrungskarenz haben, ja, richtig.
Dann müssen sie ihn über Infusion versuchen,
dann zu ernähren und Flüssigkeit haushalten zu machen, ja.
Genau.
Gut.
Ich glaube, wir haben einiges besprochen, ja.
Ja.
Richtiges Gespräch, ja.